baby teeth aren't important
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
acidic fruits will whiten your smile
oh please don't do this yes feelings
last forever
yeah they're kind of like relationships
hi i'm dr john yu i'm a pediatric
dentist in new york city and new jersey
it was between this and k-pop oh my god
hi i'm dr jason lin i'm an orthodontist
in australian teeth for a living and
today we will be debunking myths about
teeth
cavities are irreversible that's all you
bud yes it's a myth that doesn't mean
though that we've been fooling you guys
in your entire life
some cavities are reversible some are
irreversible it depends on the depth of
the cavity if you look at the three
layers of your teeth the outer layer
enamel has the capability to
re-mineralize
if the cavity is within the enamel
technically it's reversible if the
cavity penetrates to the second layer
dentin which is made up of bajillion
microtubules the bacteria can now shoot
through the tubes into the pulp which is
the center of your tooth where your
blood supply and your nerves are housed
if it goes into the second layer i may
recommend the patient hey this is most
likely going to get bigger we don't know
how fast
but we don't want to wait too long when
we have to drill into the tooth and do a
filling most times
it is irreversible and if you have a
small cavity limited to the enamel what
can you do at home you want to limit
your acid sugar intake your enamel is
the hardest substance in your body over
time just like the
brick wall of a building may wear away
with weather and storm patchwork is
needed and what patches up the lost
minerals in the enamel is the fluoride
in your toothpaste
acidic fruits will whiten your smile oh
please don't do this yeah please don't
do this guys don't deal with acid that
you have in your refrigerator the acid
will erode your teeth you may even
develop cavities erosion is real put a
picture of erosion up here
in some ways it does get whiter what
happens is like the chromogens which are
like the pigmented molecules we talked
about with the whitening the aesthetic
fruits they disperse that as well it
makes the teeth a little bit whiter but
the worst part is you're actually
weakening the teeth more than you are
actually whitening the teeth so long
term it's not great if you want to
whiten your smile
what do you recommend in office
whitening maybe once or twice a year and
then to maintain it like at home at home
lightning kits the hydrogen peroxide the
carbohydrate whitening product is a
controlled short duration treatment not
fruit stay away from your orange
braces are just for crooked teeth it's a
good one for you perfect most of my
patients i would say it's for aesthetics
but at the same time there's a lot more
reasons than just crooked teeth that you
get braces or aligners there's the
functional aspects as well obviously
underbites overbites cross bites deep
bites open bites also like grinders
traumatic occlusion any sort of spacing
issues we usually do aligners in those
patients because we have this extra
protective layer over their teeth while
straining and fixing their bites at the
same time so many parents might say my
kid's
nine years old why does he need
aesthetic teeth right he doesn't even
care yeah the patient has severe
crowding
if nothing's done impaction will occur
that's when the teeth get
jammed up in the traffic jam and that
makes the orthodontics or movement
harder when they're teenagers they're in
braces for a longer time so before the
problem gets too big we try to fix
functional components and then the
aesthetics can always follow yeah
a knocked out tooth is gone for good
time is of the essence here it's
important to know that a knocked out
tooth is not a dead tooth this is
considered an emergency because if the
tooth can be reimplanted by the dentist
within half hour one hour max yeah then
it does have a increased odds of
survival reimplantation
if it's possible
is step one it sounds crazy
but put it back in the tooth because
that's where it's home is
now if that's not possible put it in a
glass of milk
also not a joke so what type of milk
whole milk
is the best choice the milk has a
similar ph
to the cells on the root of the tooth
and if you can keep the cells alive for
longer then tooth has a better chance of
survival
there is a common misconception that you
could put the
tooth in water don't do that in fact
your saliva is better putting in a bag
of saliva water will make the cells on
the root pop diet sodas won't give you
cavities
myth guys smith i do like the effort why
does it cause cavities not necessarily
because they don't have any sugar at all
but it's because of the ph levels being
low and it's acidic there are certain
drinks that are more harmful you want to
look at the ph of them the sugar content
sports drinks soda yeah wine these
healthy
things like orange juice apple juice
they may be good for
vitamins
dental standpoint they are attacking
your teeth
sorry to rain on your parade if you look
at the ph of milk it's a lot less acidic
and it has more protective factors water
is best
water is best water and seltzer i agree
oh that's kind of a sad list yeah i know
enjoy moderation
feelings last forever
they're kind of like relationships uh
your relationship with your wife that's
gonna be forever but
in certain situations they may not you
actually see
that
a lot of the times where you need to
redo a filling it's from an existing
filling it wasn't sealed all the way it
could be that there was a little bit of
cavities underneath it and then it got a
little bit worse
and then you got to do the filling again
even after you get a filling if you're
still not flushing you're still not
brushing you can easily just get another
cavity where that existing filling was
so the maintenance on the patient's side
is also very important yeah
oh dental cleanings aren't necessary
this one's tough sometimes they're not
yeah
but let me preface it all right it is a
preventive service along with the
examination that is the most helpful
great it's not that dental cleaning
itself it's like getting an annual
checkup for some patients even a
six-month cleaning is not enough some
patients come back every three months so
it depends if you do have calculus or
very hard plaque we use in the office
scalers which are very sharp blades to
scrape off things we use a cabatron
which is an ultrasonic machine that
sprays out water and bursts these things
into pieces it's very satisfying our job
as dentists is to maintain your oral
health and there are certain things that
you can't do at home that we can do for
you so the cleaning is just one way for
us to regularly check up on you and to
make sure everything's going okay
retainers aren't for life ah this this
one hits home
i've worn a retainer for about 25 years
now in my life if you want to keep your
teeth exactly where they are it's hard
to say that hey you don't need a
retainer so the purpose of a retainer
after you get braces after you get a
liner is to hold your teeth in that
position so that your smile stays the
way that it is but then secondarily we
see a lot more grinders in the office
and with those grinders
it actually adds as an extra layer of
protection so that if they grind they're
going to grind away the plastic before
they grind away their own teeth over
time the relapse potential is less and
less but it's never zero if you want to
keep relapse incidents lowest then you
should wear it for as long as possible
so you could be on your deathbed with
your retainers
you should floss before brushing what do
you do i i floss first i do too
technically
it doesn't matter
i'm not going to make you floss before
but logically it makes sense too you're
debriding between the teeth you're
removing the bacteria you're brushing
after then you're rinsing
makes sense there's no long-term study
that's why there's no general consensus
what happens if you don't floss and you
don't clean that up to 40
of surfaces very commonly i have to
treat what's called interproximal decay
that's decay in between teeth that are
not visible to the eyes and if the
calculus builds up there over time you
get that little bit of bone loss
and if you don't clean it then that's
what leads to like the gum disease in
general i don't think it matters if you
floss before you brush the most
important thing is that you actually do
floss
baby teeth aren't important
parents often ask
why do we need to treat this cavity
can't you just pull it out he's going to
get a new one a couple years right baby
teeth are like the space holders if you
lose them a little bit too early your
teeth won't know where to go and then
they teeth can get confused a little bit
kids can also have psychological effects
from it losing two front teeth
very early three-year-old might not care
but a four or five-year-old might in
these instances uh it's important to
prioritize a child's development speech
psychological well-being
and of course the orthodontic
preservation
everyone has wisdom teeth
myth
myth that's a myth not everybody does
the wisdom teeth are the most commonly
congenitally missing teeth that means
that some people aren't born with them
how many do you have i have four i had
three so i'm less wise than echelon
they're the third molars they're the
ones all the way in the back typically
you see them if they erupt
between 17 and 21 and very commonly they
are removed because they become impacted
it's a good idea to remove them before
they become a problem like maybe in your
like late teens early 20s college
because because the bone isn't as dense
as if you were in your 30s or so so no
not everybody has wisdom teeth and when
it comes to whether or not you need to
get your wisdom teeth out that's also a
myth not everybody needs to get them out
hydrogen peroxide and baking soda are
good toothpaste replacements
myth yeah myth yeah it's missing a key
ingredient which is
fluoride
let's say that you're lost in the woods
you've lost your toothpaste
yeah tragic i know
can you use these things
i feel like it's better than nothing
it's more important to brush it off the
hydrogen peroxide and baking soda are
parts of your toothpaste but it's not
the whole thing so you're missing the
one
the muscle yeah that
is remineralizing your teeth is keeping
them healthier
so
do yourself a favor and grab some
fluoride toothpaste
you're too old to get braces
myth
100 i have patients of all ages it's not
even just like a functional thing i
think self-esteem plays a lot for adults
and kids so there's no such thing as
adult braces braces that we use for
teenagers and adults are the same but
one thing i will say is we do do a lot
of aligners for my adult patients so
these are aligners so basically
something like this you get little bumps
on your teeth
and then the tray
goes over the top of it and these this
is basically the clear alternative to
braces the issue is the compliance 90 of
the time will the patient wear it that's
why i do braces more in teenagers and
aligners more than adults
so even though we give you the trays for
two to three months at a time as
orthodontists we still want to monitor
their progress um just to make sure that
the teeth are on track they're moving
the right way and you're not at any
increased risk to lose any teeth
teeth that had root canals can't feel
huh
myth
yeah myth
but that seems logical because a root
canal procedure removes the nerve of the
tooth the reason they remove it is that
the cavity progresses into
the center of the tooth infecting the
entire chamber where the nerves and
blood supply are housed the root canal
is actually a really good option for
keeping that tooth
in your mouth for as long as possible it
can still feel
because the surrounding ligaments the
attachments to your bone for example
periodontal ligaments are still intact
technically you can still feel sensation
pressure but it shouldn't give you tooth
pain if that's what you had before it
may sound really strange that you're
leaving a dead body part
in your mouth
that kind of sounds kind of gross i know
but the alternative is no tooth or an
implant which is an artificial tooth
where you're screwing it into the bone
you can ask any dentist
in most cases where the root canal is an
option they will choose the root canal
but i will mention that because the root
canal is so technique sensitive it's
important to find someone who does it
well
you'll lose all of your teeth when
you're old
i think it really depends on how you
take care of your teeth i have patients
in their 50s 60s their teeth look better
than some of my 20 30 year olds honestly
so that's why we emphasize so much
hygiene good habits there's also a
genetic component
to aging some people
have less bone density some people
are born with really amazing teeth if
you have impeccable hygiene and good
genetics you'll be okay but if you don't
it'll come faster
the goal is to get the most mileage out
of your teeth as possible before
we need to intervene so try your best to
take care of it that's the only thing
you control you can't control genetics
so there's one thing you can take away
from this video it's important to brush
floss and you wear your retainer that's
a good one
for me the takeaways
use fluoride toothpaste
baby teeth are important and just try
your best